ah
[Music]
okay
what up guys i i am so sorry i am so
sorry i don't know what the deal is
today with this equipment
you think you're bad luck
yeah we should just end the live i can
go no
no no no stay stay stay stay it's
it's me it's not you
okay clearly
okay eva
today this is a manosphere emergency
i'm forcing my sister to listen through
this stuff because
these are important lessons okay
eva
even look look look okay so let's
we so what do you know about jada and
well so far
according to you they were the power
couple they were they're married 20
years have these two kids right
in love everyone
will would always talk about sticking it
out with your woman he'd always be like
showing her off like this
you see
i see
power couple everyone loved them
but me i always thought something was
off about them because of their kids
okay
and i had this thought before everyone
else had this thought
okay because these are their children
okay they have they have three kids i
thought they had two
oh i think this kid is from a different
marriage with will but these these two
kids they had together
but i like they're always into like
alternative lifestyle and like
non-monogamy and that stuff and i just
thought like something was weird
because like will was this white house
picket fence type of guy and i'm like
why are his kids
into this stuff
yeah does that make sense so i'm like
what what is weird so
the manosphere does a little bit of
digging right
let me make sure this is still working
fine
um
okay it is
the manosphere does a little bit of
digging and
jada also let me know if the audio is
okay in the chat
and
tupac
okay okay wait turn off the
so this is jada's ex-boyfriend do you
know who tupac is
yeah did you name a cat after him
i did have a cat that i named tupac that
is that is true
i forgot i did that
yeah it was dumb dumb and tupac
i loved tupac was one of my favorite
cats
[ __ ] ran away i know
when i went to college i came dumbledore
is still here
dumbledore is a great cat i think tupac
is hating because he ran away right
after they got off their ringworm
medication oh i think he just like hated
the medication okay so guys i'm gonna
show you
youtube
um
tupac
i wanna show you how jada would talk
about tupac
[Applause]
oh no not there
the heartbreaking okay this one
[Music]
i mean can you guys hear that in the
chat let me just double check that the
desktop audio is working
yeah let me know in the chat if it's not
i think it is but let me just
[Music]
on a recent episode of red table talk
jada interviewed robin crawford about
her relationship with whitney
but what was also revealing was what
jada shared about her friendship with
tupac shakur
it's hard to
love someone who you know has had a
legacy
at the level that
she has had
and then to lose them under tragic
circumstances because i have a very
similar situation
many speculated for years that jayla and
park dated but jada said that couldn't
have been further from the truth
rather their relationship was more like
an older brother stroke sister
relationship or even that of her father
and daughter
she implied that their relationship ran
deeper than any physical relationship
ever could
tupac and jada met at the baltimore
school of performing arts
they remained close friends right up
until his tragic death in 1996.
it was the first day and he came over to
me and introduced himself
and in high school park was a little
funny looking
definitely from looking at him wasn't
necessarily the type of cat that i would
even like deal with but as soon as he
approached me
he was like a magnet once you paid
attention to him he kind of sucked you
in
and we hit it i wish i could find the
actual actual um video where she's like
talking about him
but
let's see
oh look at this one
whatever jealous of the love jada had
for tupac okay so this is this is will
smith and they're talking about like
jada's like tupac okay uh oh [ __ ] yeah
god damn dude and you know and that was
in uh that was in the early days yeah i
was in the early days and it was like um
that's that was a big regret for me too
because i could never
um i could never open up to interact
with with poc
you know and because we had a little bit
of a thing right because you know
um
you know they grew up together
and you know they loved each other but
they never had that you know they never
had a a sexual relationship but they had
come into that age where now that was a
possibility and then jada was with me
you know so you know park had a little
thing on that um but she just loved him
like he was the image of perfection but
she was with the fresh prince you know
so it was like i i just i never could
like even we were in a room together a
couple times i couldn't speak to him you
know and you know he wasn't going to
speak to me if i wasn't going to speak
to him but
y'all have so much in common no that's
what jada was saying all the time she
was like i'm telling you y'all are so
similar you will you love him and i just
never you know that that that was a huge
regret of mine i just didn't i couldn't
i couldn't handle it you know i was just
i was the soft rapper from philly and he
was pock right
what do you think of that so far
with like how he feels yeah like what do
you think of jada and tupac's
relationship
i think it seems like they were dating
very clearly seems like they were dating
and do you think that um tupac is
like do you think jada wanted to be with
tupac or wanted to be with will
i think it's definitely tupac but two
pucks dead
yeah
so and then like you'll see videos of
jada like talking about tupac and this
is like years later
like talking about how much she like
loved him and stuff
like here this is another one
a lot of people
you know talk about my relationship with
poc and trying to figure that out you
know and that was a huge loss in my life
absolutely
yeah
because he was one of those people that
i expected to be here and my upset is
more anger
you know what i'm saying because i feel
that
he left me
and i know that's not true and it's a
very selfish way to think about it but
i really did believe that he was going
to be here for the long run right
so how does how does this sound
regretful
but it's kind of like it kind of sounds
like like she's still in love with him
doesn't it
yeah
and which is crazy because will smith
can have anybody
anybody
you know what i would do to be you think
wilson is hot right oh yeah
i would drop all my hoes will
okay i don't have any hose but
but if i did i would drop them i would
drop them okay so
then then okay so
this is going on right they're the power
couple they have the two kids
and
in the past year
um i don't know when when did the jada
and
anyone know in the chat when the jada
okay let me do jada entanglement
okay
okay so then this
so for years they're the power couple as
brightest everyone loves them
the world changes
their view on them with this
this clip in 2020 so this is like two
years ago now
they're seen as this like all-american
perfect family jada pinkett smith
brought herself to the red table and
surprisingly her husband will smith
joined her they talked about pain
healing and yes jada's entanglement with
august alcena it's all love recently
alcena revealed to the world that he was
involved in a relationship with jada
while she was still married and even
though statements were released denying
the affair pinkett smith is now
reluctantly confirming that the
relationship did indeed exist it's a
situation that i
considered private you just feel like it
ain't really nobody knows nobody's
business yeah but yeah
but now black twitter has claimed it as
they business during the 12-minute red
table talk episode jada sat down with
will to explain how she met august four
and a half years ago but the friendship
didn't turn into something more until
she and will were ready to call it quits
you and i were going through a very
difficult time yeah
and we decided i was done with you yeah
you kicked me to the curb done with you
yeah
marriages have that though
yeah we basically we broke up and then
what did you do jada well you know i
think
from there
you know as time went on i got into a
different kind of entanglement
with august yes we know entanglement is
vague as hell but thankfully will
pressed her to be more clear an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely we also got
clarity on the misconception that will
gave august permission to sleep with his
wife the only person that can give
permission in in that particular
circumstance is myself yes exactly yeah
but what
august was probably trying to
communicate
because i could actually see how he
would perceive it as
permission because we were
separated amicably
and
i think he also wanted to make it clear
that he's not a home wrecker now if
you're like us you're probably wondering
why august well we'll let jada explain
it i just wanted to feel good
it had been so
long
since i felt
good
and it was really a joy
to just
help heal somebody eventually august
broke things off and they haven't really
talked since and the smith's claim they
are now stronger than ever we
ride together we go together
bad marriage for life
okay what are you thinking
[Laughter]
what do you think of that
seemed like she was making a lot of
excuses for
right
like
she wasn't faithful yeah like she wanted
you wanted to feel something like enough
like what kind of feel something you
talking about man
maybe invite her to our talk from last
night
in our our talk from last night
yeah jada you can you can do a couch
a couch discussion with me and my sister
okay so
then after this happens the last two
years
everyone's been making fun of will
like why is he this man can have anybody
why is he putting up with
this right this is why i say guys some
men prefer women that are mean to them
and i swear to god i have seen this i
don't know what it is
but
like this guy has all the options he
could have dated margot robbie let's be
real he could uh you see them in that
movie he coulda
but he chooses to put up with this
as a man why
why like is she that special like what
so
then he becomes the butt of all the
jokes like
let me let me see if i can find one
um
should we go to
jada will
ah
let's see i think there was
some twitter oh no it's only gonna be
the new one but
like people would like clip that video
and be like well are you good at
all this stuff is like brought into the
limelight
and like even kevin samuels who's like
the father of like they call it the
manosphere it's kind of here hold on
will
jada
kevin samuels
okay this is this is like what this is
the guy who's like the godfather of the
manosphere they call him
okay
[Music]
cause
[Music]
a lot better than they are at the smith
compound
why
would you say that godfather well
cause it's often been rumored
that will and jada were in kind of an
open marriage situation
and uh
look coming from my line of business
that's not new news these things happen
all the time with rich people but you
know
i want to let will and jada explain it
themselves
so
before we get into let's get into the
broadcast cause in case you haven't
heard it
i'll let you hear it straight from
the horse's mouth herself
and let's go ahead and
and mind you everyone's talking about
this he's just one of like many people
making videos like
candlelight lighting
let's hear from will and jada themselves
uh oh
this
red table for me
um
just all the stuff that's going on
i felt like it was important to come to
the table to really clear the air
somebody made a statement for me that
wasn't a statement i made
that went
cray-cray and one of the reasons why
i wanted to come to the table is the
media the headlines
we specifically never said anything yeah
we were purposely not saying anything
any headline that says jada said or will
said or the smith said it's not true
we've specifically never said anything
right so coming to the table was like we
just felt like
it got to the point where you guys say
something yeah and
and to stop that cycle yeah you know
there's people's feelings involved right
right you know and at the end of the day
i don't like how all of this came to be
that doesn't matter
it's all love
honestly and i would usually not
you know that that would be something i
wouldn't comment on at all yeah you know
and i feel like
it's a situation that i
consider it private
you just feel like it ain't really
nobody no no nobody's business but yeah
but now black twitter has claimed it as
they business
but you know that's the thing i think
with marriages like [ __ ] always comes
out eventually
yeah there's too many people especially
if you're like on the streets and stuff
there's like even lebron james everyone
look at him as the perfect
husband but there's even like
accounts of him cheating and stuff like
i don't know the streets always talk
guys
sooner or later the streets talk i feel
like it's it's healing that needs to
happen
and i know there's a lot of stuff going
on in the world right now yeah even
though this is minuscule i do feel like
it's these kinds of things that create
the world that we're in and the idea of
not communicating
not talking about it not clearing the
air and just being as transparent
transparent and i'm i'm here with you
yeah i thank you for that because you've
been on a hell of a journey with me so
that's what we're going to start with is
that this is a very personal journey
yeah that became very public yes
absolutely for whatever reason so what
happened jada okay so let's start with
i guess about
four and a half years ago
started a i think it was about four and
a half four years ago
um
started a friendship with august
a friendship
do you have do you hook up with your
friends
very clearly no
i don't either ma'am
ma'am
and
we actually became really really good
guitar in your way i can move it if it's
in your way
any chance the slap was staged we'll get
into that later we're not there yet i'm
giving my sister doesn't know about any
of this stuff so i'm updating her good
friends
and it all started with
him just needing some help
you know
me wanting to help his
health his
mental state and he i think he was
addicted to like drugs
and stuff i think that so when she's
saying like i wanted to help don't don't
touch the mic it'll it'll um
make it too loud for the audience but
does that make sense so he was like a
drug addict
because for me that was the thing when i
when
um when og first came around he was he
was really sick
he was really really sick yeah and
the
outbreak and alcohol for him from our
family
was uh initially about his health yeah
and i mean first will's helping the man
out
at first will's taking the man in we
found all those different resources you
know to
help pull them through
and
from there you know you and i were going
through a very
difficult time yeah
and we decided i was done with joey yeah
you kicked me to the curb done with you
yeah
marriages have that though marriages
have that yeah we basically we broke up
we decided that we were going to
separate for a period of time and you go
figure out how to make yourself happy
and i'll figure out how to what do you
think when people say that like i need
to figure out how to make myself happy
do you think that's like a real thing
and reason to leave a marriage
i think that if you're not happy in the
marriage when you figure out how to make
yourself happy you're going to be out of
the marriage
like
do you think people just say that when
they want to leave loki like what's up
they don't want to say that they want to
leave
[Music]
it's like a break
okay okay okay
what
oh
well at that particular point in time it
was indefinite yeah i really felt like
we could be over
yeah no we were over and then what did
you do jada well you know i think
from there you know as time went on i
got into a different kind of
entanglement
with august and one thing i want to get
clear about and clean up one of the
things that was kind of swirling in the
press about
you giving permission which is
uh
you know the only person that can give
permission in
in that particular
circumstances myself yes exactly yeah
but what
august was probably trying to
communicate
because i could actually see how he
would perceive it as
permission because we were
separated amicably
and
i think he also wanted to make it clear
that he's not a home wrecker
which he's not i'm thinking so i mean
because this is do you think he's a home
wrecker
august yeah no i think jada is yeah
well but i think it's kind of dirty if
someone like imagine okay imagine
i don't want to use this example with
our family
but you can think of some people that
we've taken in right because our family
does that like we always take in strays
right
now imagine if one of the strays hooked
up with mom
after dad took him in
like the level of disrespect
yeah like that's that's that's so
disrespectful it's disrespectful but
jadis still like
yeah they have to you have to be in the
marriage to wreck it yeah no for sure
but i i don't
i still think that's dirty but we'll
continue your red table and you like
brought yourself to the red table
i think um you need to say clearly what
happened as far as what you and i
decided we were gonna
take our space and what happened yeah
and then i got into an entanglement with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely i was in a lot
of pain and i was very broken
now in the process of that relationship
i definitely realized that
you can't find happiness outside of
yourself fair use
okay do you think
that
if the tables were turned and a girl a
guy did the same thing he said i was
really broken
and he hooked up with a 20 year old
drug addict
do you think people would how do you
think people would perceive that do you
think it'd be different than a girl
doing the same thing
yeah i'd be very negatively will get
canceled yeah
like isn't that crazy but like she
doesn't get canceled when she she like
she's kind of taking advantage of a guy
who's like addicted to drugs
yeah
it's not
that kind of nuts
continues and luckily enough
you and i were also going through a
process of healing in a much different
manner i would definitely say and we did
everything that we could to get away
from each other only to realize that
that wasn't
possible so we come to the rear table so
i mean i'm in the jaded position right
now so you know you
during that time launched into an
interaction
with august what do you feel like
interaction entanglement you were
looking for
i just wanted to feel good
it had been so
long
since i felt
good
and it was really a joy
to just
will i will take her place
you can cheat on me
[Music]
oh
hannah you should be ashamed of yourself
i'm just kidding
kill somebody yeah
no three kids is a lot
they're older but for you will sorry i'm
done i think that has a lot to do with
my
codependency
which is another thing that i had to
learn to break in this cycle just that
idea of needing to fix and being drawn
to people that need help whether it's
your health or whether it's your
addictions there's something i think i
have that a little bit in me i think us
davises we kind of like strays a little
bit
[Laughter]
i don't know about me yet but you
it's not just me it's our other siblings
too why is that yeah i mean adam did
bring chaz home one day and then
he did
we do be we bringing people home
i i had my last boyfriend moved in with
us
yeah sorry i i relate a little bit not
not that much no no drug addicts about
that childhood trauma
um
that
feels as though it can be fixed
through
fixing people
versus
fixing me yeah
and i think that that whole process what
do you think of what she's saying so far
a lot of excuses for
trying to like she's trying to say i
cheated in fancy terms
see
eva's my little hippie sister but she's
not stupid
i'm calling me a hippie
what should i call you
she's not looking she's wearing tie-dye
it's scooby-doo
what's scooby doo
a crime fighting show
i rest my case
really showed me that
and taught me that
and i'm really grateful for that lesson
i feel like that husband like i'm with
you at the press conference
now i got to be with you at the press
conference while you like to tell the
world uh about your transgressions
well like i love i love my baby i'ma
stand by my baby no matter what well you
know i think that's right he should
stand by his baby no matter what no
do you think that love is conditional
yeah yeah do you think if you're being
treated like [ __ ] you should you think
if you get cheated on you should leave
i think it depends okay what do you
think it depends on
like the conditions of cheating like if
they just cheated like
you know
really
that's interesting well
i think when you have kids it's not
about you anymore so i understand that
but your kids are grown
i don't think they're grown yet i think
they're like 12.
no they're they're older i think they're
over 18.
but the thing is like
i feel like
at some point like i think jada was kind
of a bad influence on the kids because i
see like the way they grew up and i just
don't get that coming from well i mean
they are old like all the like open
relationships and that type of stuff
like i just that seems like a jada
like new age thing yeah which i guess
some people might be for that just i
personally wouldn't want my kids like
being raised around that type of stuff
or watching the mother of your kids f a
20 year old
and like the thing is i bet willow knew
because that's her friend it was like
her daughter's friend yeah
like imagine imagine if will aft his
daughter's friend
like wouldn't that be
nuts be nasty
i definitely i definitely understand
why it would look that way or feel that
way but i actually don't look at it as a
transgression at all through that
particular journey i learned so much
about myself and was able to really
confront a lot of emotional immaturity
emotional insecurity and i was really
able
to do some really deep healing you know
and as i came through and started to
realize certain things about you and i
he decided
to
break all communication with me which
was totally understandable right
and i let that be and hadn't talked to
him since right so it is a little weird
that all this stuff is coming out now
since this was yeah cause for me that's
right what did she say
wait what did you how did it end
did you hear that
no
okay wait i just want to see
as a transgression at all through that
particular journey i learned so much
about myself and was able to really
confront a lot of
emotional immaturity emotional
insecurity and i was really able
to do some really deep healing
you know and as i came through and
started to realize certain things about
you and i he decided
to
break all communication with me right
which was totally understandable right
um
and i let that be and had him so he like
pumped and dumped
and talked to him since
so it is a little weird that all this
why do they call it deep healing
like why do girls do this
i don't know hannah how did you heal by
getting ran through
like what
how does that make you a better person
you're you're asking me
don't do that if you get married someday
don't do that coming out now since this
was yeah because for me this was years
ago right you know so the fact that it's
uh coming up now and i think it could
feel weird for people that we're
laughing and and talking about it but it
happened so long ago you know and
our experiences of
working through it fighting through it
talking through it and
therapizing right through it i think
that the why now is weird yeah when i
say it's been a huge healing on my life
and just what i had to confront and
discover
you know about myself
the ugly truths
and the beauty
so what are you talking about lady
what
the ugly truth of getting [ __ ] down
like
something that i felt like wasn't really
you want your tea i want my tea okay
here you go
ready to be discussed because it hadn't
been that
healing because he hasn't wanted to you
know og and i haven't talked in
okay i'm gonna like fast forward to
where
kevin samuels talks marriage is hard
welcome to real world stuff folks
welcome to real world stuff
if this is your first time seeing it
understand something that is far more
the norm
when it comes to power couples people
who marry
and people who stay together for a long
time if you know anything about your
grandma and grandfather you probably
still find out stuff that you didn't
know
you probably met some uh half brothers
and stuff at funerals
you know when you uh on the other side
of town i was telling people
but this is far more un far more common
than a lot of us like to think but my
real question is this
that was grandma and grandpa
i want to fast forward up to
grandma and grandpa are gone they're
dead that was the silent generation
after them it was the baby boomers
and the baby boomers are people from
like 56
uh to around 70
are my parents boomers
how old's dad
[Laughter]
mom and dad are in their 50s
well i think mom's like 52 dads 57 maybe
they're five years apart mom yes dad's
57 that's gross
okay
eight dad's like an elder
baby boomers
those people are still alive
but the late baby boomers those are the
people from like 56 to 62.
all of generation x which is from 40 to
56 and then late millennials from 36
to 40.
i gotta ask the question
do these black women really want to be
married
uh if you go back
in your memory
alicia keys did a song that everybody
thought was just so great
unbreakable
we could fight like i can tina
or give it back like bill and camille
the cosby's
be rich like oprah and steadman
or ins or instead struggle like flo and
james evans
we could act it out like will and jada
or like kamara and russell
making paper
all in the family like the jacksons like
the jacksons and even have enough kids
to make i can't i just want to go to the
part where he talks about
okay i can't find it because kevin
samuel's broadcaster so long but
basically
he says that will was jada's second
choice
and you can kind of hear how she talks
about tupac like she wanted to be with
tupac
and she like feels like she settled for
will
would you agree with that like based on
what you've seen
yeah yeah like
um and so
like
basically like the whole world is
talking about this because this is eva
you don't even understand this is like a
cultural moment like people love jada
and well i called this mom mom loves
will smith and i said to mom before any
of this came out i said something weird
is going on in that house because
there is no way they should be like this
young and so open to like open
relationships
like even even the people in our family
right
if you're 16 in an open relationship
and and you're telling the world about
this
people do weird [ __ ] when they're young
but it's like the culture like when it's
coming from your their family you can
tell because it's like
like they'll be like 16 17 and publicly
talking about this
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think anyone in our family
would do like a full-on like open
relationship and if they did they sure
as hell wouldn't go on a public platform
and say
like it had to be something in the
family would you agree with that
yeah like that had to be something with
how they were raised so i called this i
called i didn't know how far it went but
i was like there is something weird
going on in that family
okay
so now this brings us so two years of
this this brings us to last night
did you see this video
who hasn't seen the video tick tock
takes every single big thing like that
and rampages it through the internet oh
my gosh why is this slow like it was on
my for you page
two minutes after it happened make sure
this is still going
okay
it sure okay
will
smith
slap
okay let's let's do this
stop saying stop mouthing help me you
are fine you are absolutely fine stop
acting like
she's fine
that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh
[Laughter]
okay well smith
joke
jada
i wanna is this the full and it looks
like it okay this might be the full one
you know who's got the hardest job
tonight
javier beldem and his wife are both
nominated
now if she loses he can't win
he is praying that will smith wins like
please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane too can't wait
to see it all right
[Applause]
okay so look at
i think he thought it was funny at first
do you see that yeah and then she is
like pissed off
because like these woke women they just
can't take a joke
like
okay if someone and i understand like
she's alopecia or whatever but if
someone i have seizures guys
if someone made a joke about strobe
lights with seizures like i'm not gonna
be a [ __ ] about it
i think it's funny still
like i get mocked at school for like
having the possibility of being like
because i've never had a seizure before
yeah like we all know it's gonna happen
one day
like at this point it's just a comical
joke and he could have made a joke about
august that'd be way worse yeah you got
a joke about being bald
like that's it
anyway so look it she's she's not he
doesn't think it's funny he's laughing
[Music]
that was that that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh i'm guessing there was
some look where she like looked at will
and was like
you know
yeah and now
oh wow
[Applause]
wow
oh my god
will smith just smacked the [ __ ] out of
me
all right do you think that it was
do you think it was fake because some
people are saying the slap was fake
it kind of just it doesn't look real but
also
like both of those people are actors
like it's very easy to just play off
but also it's very easy to recreate so
i don't know i think it was real
to be honest i think it was real but
a lot of people in the manners fear
think it was
fake out your [ __ ] mouth
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i janja keep my wife's
name out your [ __ ] mouth i'm going to
okay
also very unprofessional about it what
he was very unprofessional about it
like chris rock did a great job being
professional after it happened yeah
like like it's not like it we're at some
little little like this is the oscars
like
yeah like he could have
because some people are saying because
the ratings were low they thought of
this but i don't know
i guess will is a pretty good actor so
this very well could have been fake
but i don't know i see where she was
coming from
oh wow they do yeah they really show me
a picture of gi jane
a lot of people say it was staged it was
state i don't know
i don't i don't think it was staged but
i could be wrong
i i don't
i just think that the slap would have
been too far and i don't you're not
allowed to swear on tv
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay
yeah i think he handled it very well and
he didn't even okay i want to see will
smith's
response
speech
i haven't seen this one have you seen
this
what he said after he got no
um
okay this is
i know
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you why are you crying
as if we just in this business you got
to be able to have did you say is he
crying as if we hit him
guys send super chats there's 110 of you
on here
come on like four dollars really
respectfully all the money is going
towards a new camera and new equipment
so
some super chats we'll read them i'm
gonna continue stop stop saying help me
stop it
people disrespecting you
and you gotta smile and you gotta
pretend like that's okay
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
um
so he won the award
that's going to be embarrassing
oh my god
this is a beautiful moment and i'm not
i'm not i'm not crying
for winning an award it's not it's not
about winning an award for me it's about
being able to shine light
on all of the people tim
and and trevor and zach
and tsunaya and demi and anjanu and the
entire cast and crew of king richard and
venus and serena the entire williams
family
um
art imitates life i look like the crazy
father list like they said
i look like crazy father just like they
said about richard williams um
but love will make you do crazy things
being able to love and care for my
mother and my family my wife
um i'm taking up too much time
there you go hannah thank you
for
this honor
thank you
for hold on this moment and thank you on
behalf of
richard and and oracine the entire
williams family
thank you uh
hoping academy invites me back thank you
okay one
let's start he's saying love makes you
do crazy things boy you're simping and
thank you for the 10 super chat and the
20dkk super chat i appreciate it guys
like
i want to do streams like this all the
time
um but i need to see that the demand is
there so when you guys send me money i'm
not even keeping it right now on april
1st everything is going to be going
towards a new camera and some new
equipment so all donations not even
keeping everything's going back into the
studio okay you could also send her
money to buy me a nice birthday gift
yeah her birthday's coming up too on the
forum
thanks for the remembering hannah um
okay okay okay um but thank you to
justin loftland for ten dollars um jan
read this
road god made float i don't know but
okay so
and then jim bob says i thought gi jane
was a strong female character appreciate
you guys um so
why is he saying that love
is like he's doing it out of love
like imagine imagine okay
if i
slapped someone over like the smallest
joke and i was like i did it out of love
you did this because you could not
control your emotions well
don't blame love on this one what do you
think
what do you
what do you think
no yeah definitely not out of love
with the headphones
yeah
oh god
that's the last video we're watching
but
oh there you go okay
um no
like why
this is like what happens though i think
when you you wife
girls that are for the streets
like none of this would have happened
but this is what i say like some
i'm gonna move the camera a little more
this way now because we don't need to
sit over there
because of the headphones
like
some men literally prefer women
like they literally prefer women that
like disrespect them have you seen that
[Music]
yeah but the the difference with girls
though is like the traits that men find
attractive in men
it's like called the dark triad so like
for example the same traits that make
someone a criminal make them a ceo
yeah i've heard about that actually i'm
saying but like men it's not like
they're supposed to be attracted to like
fit feminine friendly girls like that's
typically what they say but then you see
stuff like this where like a guy has all
the options in the world and he picks a
girl that's for the streets why
you could've had margot robbie my dude
like marva like imagine having margot
robbie like who who do you think's
hotter jada or marco
[Music]
she turns
actually i'm not telling them how old
she's turning okay i can send it in the
chat
like i just i don't get it because some
guys like
it's like they have so many options
and i found this where like if you're
super nice to a guy like they think it's
like weird almost like why are you being
nice to me yeah like suspicious
have you
seen that because you're young like do
you see that with girls at your school
like guys like girls that are like
meaner sometimes
yeah i feel like i'm a nice girl and yet
here i am
they also just like the girls that are
like
oh that sounds wrong but like innocent
they like girls that are innocent yeah
but they're not actually like
i'm not gonna say her name because i
don't want to get like
right she at the school
but like
she's just the kind of person that like
you like you can't talk about sex around
her because she's like
she's just so weird
it's like it's guys like her is she
really pretty
no
really do you always like her no
yeah
really she's like the [ __ ] boy at the
school but she's like the kind girl
who's like i'm waiting till marriage
uh well her boyfriend's getting really
frustrated with it
well don't get me wrong like i do think
guys like like
the majority of guys do in my opinion
like nice girls and prefer like the
innocent like but there's a certain type
of guy i've just seen they prefer women
for the streets i don't know why
i don't know what it is
um let me read some of these super chats
um
okay the streets can someone answer the
phone we're calling
um sam men demessa
free pearls little sis that hashtag help
me
stop saying that you it made you ten
dollars
you know what you can keep saying
willa's just created more problems for
himself now the internet is going to
fixate on their
problems more
two pounds tanisha
merzoki thank you jackques van hout i'm
sorry i'm so bad at names like i'm so
bad
um for the birthday 10 pounds thank you
and guys um
at the end of the month i need to make
like
i'd say like 150-ish more dollars for um
for
the camera so i really do appreciate all
the super chats like you guys
you make you make this job worth doing
you stop telling them you're turning 18.
stop it stop it
um
why do you guys let me know in the chat
why do you think
okay so some people in the chat say that
they think well settled too young like
he got married too young and he should
have waited because he would have had
better options
i think yes but also that was just the
time
i just he was on the fresh prince of
bel-air though like guys like do you
really think that that was the only girl
he had available to him
being on tv back then
come on
i know he's like bigger and better today
and if he went out into the dating
market today like he would probably get
a hotter chick than he could have been
but at some point like
men
choose these girls just like girls
choose toxic guys like there's certain
types of guys that in my opinion like
like to be
controlled um
two dollar super chat charles guitar i
guess i'm third place this episode
um skyler says the the ginger sis is
a bagoo
is that your friend
this is his second marriage though
the sex was good he that's his second
marriage was the first girl normal did
he leave her did she leave him the sex
was good so he fell in love he's a simp
look at this is what i say certain guy
girls guys can make a guy fall in love
like they're a hoes they know their hoes
they don't care
and they get really good at certain
skills in men i'm telling you fall in
love with these females i have seen it
i have seen it
i'm not saying they should but like it
just is what it is
but what do you think so what do you
think do you think he should have left
like early
when when do you think he should have
left her
or do you think it's right that he
stayed for the family
well his kids are older now so i feel
like at this point just go but i also
think he may fear like i don't think
they have a prenup or anything like that
oh yeah i didn't even bring that up
how much does will smith work 500
million i think something like that like
he's worth a lot
well oh gosh
do you think at that point though it's
like even if they split half he's still
rich like stupid rich
beyond
like what are you gonna do with 500
million that you couldn't do with 250
million
are you reading the comments but no i'm
trying to figure out how much he's worth
oh okay he's worth 350 and jada is worth
50.
yeah she's not bad looking she wasn't
always gi jane given the red table talk
and how she twists the language i'm
banking on her being a manipulator
since when is defending your wife a simp
it's not like jado some girl he barely
knows okay but the what simp behavior is
like he laughed at the joke at first and
everyone thought it was funny and scent
behavior is changing your actions based
on the girl instead of like based on
your intuition and what you think is
right
so he he laughed at the joke then saw
jada's reaction
and then got mad
where
if someone's like alpha like i hate that
term but like more alpha and like a
leader
he would tell the girl to chill out
because she should have it's a joke
that's what they do the academy awards
is they
they roast everyone there you know
that's gonna happen and yeah and he
could have made a joke about you getting
railed by freaking a 20 year old drug
addict
like
what's worse
um
thank you eat godly
you guys
look at you guys don't you don't want to
simp but you know what i will take will
smith
um
okay
awesome do you think do you think his
career is over now
no it's will smith like
yeah like
[Music]
oh i think you're gonna keep going no
i'm also like that's why people are like
saying it's like stage though i feel
like they wouldn't have like there's so
many other things that they could have
done to get more publicity that have
will smith
slap it's hard because these people are
actors so they're really good at faking
[ __ ]
i don't know i don't think
will is being incongruent so it was okay
for jada to get railed by his friend his
son's friend
but he lost control of his emotions
because of a joke about jada's dumb
haircut
and she still has hair in the haircut
too like
he's not like mocking her for being bald
that's the thing like if someone called
me a ginger like i wouldn't care grow a
pear
like honestly
um
what kind of sex was jada having with
tupac she must still be dignitized
um
okay sir
look
i'm gonna keep that thought to myself
um
his career isn't over two dollars will
smith talk smack now that i'm in the
room fools
will sim
um is there any other thoughts you had
because otherwise i'm gonna end the
stream i think they've covered it don't
think his career is over i think it was
real do you think it was real or staged
i just think i think it was real just
because why would they do it at the
oscars like there's so many other things
they could have done tv ratings that's
what they're saying yeah but i just feel
like there's so many other things that
they could have done other than will
smith
smacking something although the smack
did seem kind of fake like just like
looking at it seemed fake i just think
will doesn't know how to like punch
somebody that's what yeah take on it was
he's just kind of
he's not a puncher you know what i mean
um
yeah that's another thing two non-white
people fighting on tv isn't something
those communities want
yeah
no oh that's true
yeah that's true
um
is it she has alopecia is it really a
haircut if you're genetically going bald
but guys
i'm sorry your insecurities that's what
people can come for
like people can
that's
someone going to call me a tall pale
ginger like
i have seizures if someone made fun of
my seizures
i don't care
like like grow a pair you guys are grown
ass adults so gingers get mocked all the
time all the time like we hate it on
fresh and like what the [ __ ]
like like what do you
uh keep it going 27 thank you emin
daniel keep it going there's always
something to discuss
i don't know we've
i don't know we've discussed
everything will grew up fighting in
philly he knows how to take a punch
she has alopecia and 50 million dollars
like that's the thing when people okay
when people on tv because look it guys i
am not rich i am not
how broke am i very broke how how bro
trying to get this channel running but i
know that part of my job is you guys get
to make fun of me and you do
don't
don't get me wrong like people in my
tic-tac comments hate me right now do
they hate me
you're still wearing my necklace oh do
you want it yeah i'm sorry i like
actually forgot i was wearing it i did
two until i saw shimmer um
and so i'm like you guys are paid to get
made fun of
and you get fame like all this [ __ ]
do you think that the fame is like worth
it
what like okay because we we see things
from like a rich kid's perspective sort
of right
but we are but our parents have a
different type of like we're not famous
yeah we're just hard workers yeah and
like
it's almost like sometimes the fame is
so hard on a family because i don't
think i would never actually want to be
like famous like will smith famous like
i don't want people in my business all a
bit like that yeah
no and that's why
even um
our family like
youtube is so different than like
like i want i want to be famous because
i want money so at night
well it's easy to make money off of
everything when you're famous yeah
but i don't want to be famous famous i
just want to be like youtube yeah like
people come up to you every now and then
like oh you're hannah but like
pearl they know me as well i know
i refuse to call you pearl i will never
call you pearl until the day i die
that's fair that's fair two dollars from
biggie i hate it when i hated will
showed that black men are emotional
you're laughing probably woman getting
dygmatized is real
um
let's see any other comments
wait till you see what weak men are
capable of jordan peterson no it's not
worth it
two dollars as a black man this
situation is embarrassing i don't speak
on like because people will say oh you
shouldn't even be commenting on this
because you're white but i'm like i
would comment on this if two
any race like what i'm saying how do you
expect me not to comment on manosphere
gold like get out it's also like
everybody's commenting on it it's not
like it's just you you think you got
you think i'm not gonna comment when
someone got [ __ ] slapped on national tv
at the oscars bro i'm a business woman
you got me [ __ ] up like
get out of here
um a lot of powerful men want to be
dominated at home it explains will and
jada
he only did it after jada looked at him
that was the symbol yeah that's what i'm
saying it wouldn't be one thing
if the way will reacted immediately was
like no that was too far but he clearly
didn't think it was too far because he
was laughing
and then he's trying to make excuses on
stage after like i did it for love no
no and that's the thing when they talk
about like guys that make a lot of money
are now he's alpha like some of them are
still beta i hate these terms but it's
like what the mana sphere uses
like it's
like some guys just want to be
controlled i don't know why
um
like you think i won't comment on
manosphere gold you got me f'ed up
okay
yeah so my final thoughts
final thoughts will is a simp um i think
you should leave and find
a 25 year old redhead
in the united states
you're 17.
a 20 a 25 year old
legal redhead
um in england but i'll move to you will
um
and you could
i think she's eating right now
what would you say
did you say [ __ ]
i'm curious as you could do you guys
even hear that
i bet they could i think if you whisper
into the mics you can hear it
[Laughter]
um
that's my final thought though i think
he's a semp
i think this won't ruin his career i
think he'll be fine he's too good of an
actor
um he's too popular an actor oh my god i
think he should find a girl that's not
for the streets
i think that look at your phone
um
maybe will was willing to be a dominant
what maybe will was
able to be a domine stem and not tupac i
don't know what that means
a diamond
diamond domain stem
do you know what that means
google it
domain asmr
stop
[Music]
and i think she's
i think you know what eating means you
think i'm eating
no i don't i didn't oh my god what is
that like eating like eating it up
eating what
[Music]
eating
does that mean like i think i'm cool no
it means you think you're
eating you're not on the right side of
tick-tock
that's someone commented that on my
tick-tock they were like she thinks
she's eating right now and i'm like [ __ ]
i'm hungry is it by chance
somebody with the name chicken nugget
um i don't think so
is that amelia
no was it you no
who is it
somebody i know let's see
oh yikes she really thought she ate this
up
that's what i said no it wasn't it was
express hoe
all right good
chris rock
[Music]
actually handled it well in my opinion
that's my final thought on chris rock
you were a store and tick tock and you
don't know what eating means i would not
call myself a star on tick tock but i
think i i like my youtube audience so
much better than my tic-tock audience
and it's smaller but i like prefer you
guys
my talk audience annoys me
because they can't
think it's like everything's offensive
put put that clip on tick tock i just i
mean it i'm sorry
i like some of them
but the majority every time i post a
clip about anything that matters they're
like
skylar chicken nine oh is that your
friend that you're on face time with
maybe okay
[Music]
i mean what are your final thoughts on
this situation
i think chris rock really did handle it
well yeah jada so give me give me
opinions on anyone everyone jada pick me
jay doesn't pick me she just seems like
a pick me
she's a how are you pick me if you're
effing 20 year old drug dealers and
you're making a big deal out of it
making excuses for yourself as if you
did nothing wrong oh so that's a pick me
behavior pick me behavior is just
wanting to be the center of attention
like wanting
but like you do nothing wrong
oh so it's like the guy's always wrong
yeah it's like you're never at fault
like
like guys like pick me like instead of
just saying i was horny and
yeah 20 year old being like it was to
help my emotional stability guys
you crazy people
i can pick me would just sit there and
be like go get the bell
go get the what belle
what's the bell
that work
i don't get it
you won't get it but skyler will
um okay what about will smith what do
you think of will
he will i turn 18 in less than a week
stop
stop no pick me
see pick me
okay that's fine maybe i am
um
so
stop talking [ __ ] in the microphone
um
say it to my face
well you're gonna go back and re-watch
this like i see you do so
okay um then
what's your thought
on the kids any thoughts
well they haven't really said anything
have they i don't think so honestly i
don't think they should like that just
would put them in the drama
okay what do you think about
um
we got jada
what do you think you think chris rock
handled it well he handled it really
well like that was he was very
professional about it instead of like
going back to like punching will smith
and what about
what do you think will should do
i think it's hard because like i
wouldn't want like i know it's like he's
so rich that's like doesn't even matter
but also like it's still your money that
you earned oh so you would stay because
of the money i would be separated but i
wouldn't do a divorce
oh so you think he should stay with her
and just hook up with the hot hoes no i
mean like don't stay with her but don't
legally get divorced because if they
don't legally divorce then she he's not
gonna lose any money
oh
okay like they're divorced but not
actually okay
so
then could he like get remarried and
stuff
i'm already married but like well i mean
he would just get a new girlfriend yeah
like he could like date whatever it's
like they're not together then there's
no there's nothing between them except
for being legally married okay
i'm with you i agree
i think
but actually i would probably get the
divorce because like you want to start i
would just divorce
her find someone 20 years
20 years younger
um and
yeah marry her that's what i would do if
i was him
but i understand the money i just think
like what's the difference 500 million
250 million i know but i'm just saying
that like it's still your money though
how does he cuz like she also gets
future money that's the other thing like
if he divorces now
let's see how old is he although i mean
also he probably could
they probably should probably get less
money knowing that she's the one who
caused the
will smith age
i don't know how old is he i was 53
you did a 53 year old
i mean will smith is will smith like
that's even a little old for me oh my
gosh i still would though
[Laughter]
i mean adelpha's adelph like you gotta
take what you get
um
okay
still um
okay
all right guys thank you so much for
watching thank you for the super chats
this stream
um this is probably me and eva's last
stream together because we're going to
ireland tomorrow so i'm not bringing
our equipment if we did do a stream and
just be on a phone or something
but i really appreciate the super chats
again all the super chats i'm not even
keeping at this point um at some day i
will take the money i'm not gonna lie to
you someday you guys need to pay me for
my time
but for the
for the time being um all the money is
going towards i want to get a new camera
and new lights there's going to be a big
update um
the 1st of april i'm getting paid
so there's gonna be like a big update
coming soon i'm really excited for it
um there's gonna be like more mics new
cameras you'll you'll see but i wanna
get the like nicer camera so all super
chats that you guys send are like really
appreciated and anything else is to cash
app which is hannah pearl davis
h-a-n-n-a-h
p-e-a-r-l-d-a-v-i-s gmail.com wait
that's paypal that's paypal and then
uh just pearly things on um
cash out that's what it is so again
appreciate you guys love you
don't forget to subscribe